.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Ein Polizist auf der Suche
nach gestohlenem Weissmehl.
Damals eine wertvolle Ware.
Mehl ist während des Krieges
rationiert.
Die Suche wird zum Auftakt
zu einer der grössten Spionageaffären
der Schweiz.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Italienische Flugblätter?
"Viva la rivoluzione proletaria!"
"Es lebe
die proletarische Revolution!"
Eigenartig.
* Die Musik endet. *
Bundesgericht Lausanne.
Ich begebe mich
auf die Suche nach Akten,
die den Zufallsfund
im Estrich dokumentieren.
Erstmals lässt das Bundesgericht
ein Fernsehteam in seine Archivräume.
Ich finde bisher unbekannte Dokumente
über die Spionageaffäre.
Und auch die Flugblätter
sind über 100 Jahre später noch
fein säuberlich aufbewahrt -
als Beweismittel.
Ich stosse auf einen beschlagnahmten
Pass, lautend auf einen Hans Schreck.
Schreck, so wird meine Recherche bald
zeigen, spielt eine Schlüsselrolle.
Und ich realisiere:
Auch Waffen sind im Spiel:
Handgranaten.
"Vorsicht! Nicht verbeulen!",
eine deutsche Aufschrift.
Da stimmt doch etwas nicht.
Und da gibt es sogar noch mehr.
Eigenartig.
* Telefonklingeln *
Ja, Heusser.
Was?
Flugblätter
mit einem Aufruf zur Revolution?
Was noch? Waffen?
Sprengstoff? Nein.
Granaten? Was für eine Aufschrift?
"Vorsicht! Nicht verbeulen!" -
das ist ja unglaublich.
Gut, danke.
Otto Heusser,
eidgenössischer Untersuchungsrichter.
Er soll den Waffenfund aufklären.
Heusser ist ein Mann
mit einer Mission:
Für ihn sind die Waffen und erst
recht die aufrührerischen Flugblätter
eine Kampfansage:
(Lukas Vogel)
Otto Heusser war ein Mensch,
der sehr streng
und sehr militärisch gedacht hat.
Er war sehr ...
... bürgerlich,
bis sogar rechtsextrem.
In seinen späteren Lebensjahren
stand er
der rechtsextremen Bewegung nahe.
Wir befinden uns im Jahr 1918,
in der Zeit des Ersten Weltkriegs.
Seit vier Jahren
tobt der blutige Krieg.
(Julia Richers)
Es war ein sehr gewalttätiger Krieg,
mit Millionen von Toten.
Er läutete eine Art
Zeitalter der Extreme ein.
Es war der erste Krieg
mit unglaublicher Massengewalt,
auch mit Massenvernichtungswaffen,
moderner Technologie
sowie Massenmedien
und Propaganda.
Die Kaiserreiche Deutschland
und Österreich-Ungarn,
Mittelmächte genannt,
kämpfen gegen Frankreich, England
und das Zarenreich Russland.
Dieses Bündnis
nennt sich "die Entente".
Später schliesst sich
auch Italien der Entente an.
(Jakob Tanner)
Es war ein sehr gewalttätiger Krieg.
Über vier Jahre hinweg
starben jeden Tag
durchschnittlich 6'000 Soldaten,
in allen Kriegsparteien.
Es wurden auch
ganz neue Waffensysteme erfunden,
z.B. Panzer oder Gasgranaten.
Im Ersten Weltkrieg gab es
zum ersten Mal Kampfgaseinsätze.
Es war ein Krieg, der sozusagen auf
industrieller Ebene geführt wurde
und der entsprechend auch zu einem
unglaublichen Blutbad führte,
zu einem unglaublichen Massaker.
Das war für die Menschen damals
ein absoluter Schock.
Spionage wird in diesem Abnützungs-
krieg ebenfalls zur neuen Waffe.
Es ist das erste Mal,
dass so viel in Nachrichtendienste
investiert wird.
Es wird schnell klar,
dass Informationen in diesem Krieg
von entscheidender Bedeutung sind.
Deshalb nimmt Spionage in diesem
Konflikt eine so wichtige Rolle ein.
Die Schweiz war
ein ganz wichtiger Spionagestandort,
oder man könnte auch sagen
Drehscheibe oder Plattform.
Einerseits war die Schweiz neutral.
Das war für die befeindeten Mächte
ein sehr wichtiger Punkt,
weil es bedeutete,
dass man die Spionage
nicht im Feindesland
risikoreich betreiben musste,
sondern dass man auf neutralem Boden
den Feind ausspionieren konnte.
Die Schweiz
wird zum Spionageparadies.
Im Bundesarchiv in Bern finde ich
denn auch unzählige Spionage-Akten.
Während das kriegsführende Ausland
überführte Spione sofort exekutiert,
erhalten sie in der Schweiz milde
Strafen und werden ausgeschafft.
So finde ich hier das Verzeichnis
der wegen Militärspionage
in der Schweiz
ausgewiesenen Ausländer.
Hunderte von Spionen
schickte die Schweiz zurück
in ihre Herkunftsländer.
(Jakob Tanner) Spionage
war damals ein Riesenbusiness.
Gemäss britischen Schätzungen
gab es 150'000 Spione,
die zudem noch Hunderttausende
von Helfern hatten.
Es waren ja
verschiedene Organisationen -
die katholische Kirche
oder auch Kriegsverwundete,
die stets auch
eine Informationsquelle darstellten.
Die Kriegsverwundeten Ð
Tausende kommen im Rahmen einer
humanitären Aktion in die Schweiz.
Sie werden Teil des
weitverzweigten Spionage-Netzwerks:
Das hatte mit der Hager
Landrechtsverordnung zu tun.
Die Schweiz
hatte sich bereit erklärt,
Kriegsverletzte aller Kriegsparteien
aufzunehmen.
Das war natürlich auch wichtig
für die Spionage,
weil viele mit diesen
Kriegsversehrten Kontakt aufnahmen.
Von 1915 bis 1918
werden rund 70'000 Verwundete
in der Schweiz interniert.
Selbstverständlich
dienen auch diese Menschen
dem Nachrichtendienst als Quelle.
Die wussten zwar vielleicht nicht
Bescheid über die grosse Strategie
oder das nächste Vorhaben,
aber sie konnten sich
zu den Taktiken äussern:
Wie gehen sie beim Sturm
gegnerischer Festungen vor?
Oder beim Angriff
auf Schützengräben?
Sie konnten auch etwas über
die Stimmung sagen, die herrschte.
Dieses Wissen
war eine Art kleine Puzzleteile,
anhand derer man sich dann
ein Bild vom Gegner machen konnte,
denn man hatte sonst wenig Zugang
zu soliden Informationen.
Die neue Spionageserie "Davos 1917".
Ganz formidabel,
erhöhen Sie die Dosis um 3 Grad.
Auch in der SRF-Serie
werden Kriegsverletzte gepflegt -
und dienen den Geheimdiensten
als Quelle.
Dass Sie mir jetzt nicht noch
einen Platz
bei den feinen Leuten
an der Sonne verlangen.
Tut das weh?
Spüren Sie das?
- Nein.
Dann sind Sie bald so weit.
Wo ist Herr Kohlmann?
Ohne die Kriegsverletzten
wären die Hotels leer.
Die Aktion ist überaus interessant
für die Schweizer Hotellerie.
Denn der wichtige
florierende Wirtschaftszweig
ist durch den Krieg völlig am Boden.
Es gibt keinen Tourismus mehr,
die meisten Hotels stehen leer.
Deshalb werden Internierte
in Hotels untergebracht,
sie werden hier
gepflegt und ernährt.
Sie arbeiten auch,
sie werden ausgebildet.
Und vor allem:
Die kriegsführenden Staaten
zahlen für die Internierung
ihrer Verwundeten.
Das ermöglicht der Schweizer
Hotellerie zu überleben.
Mama.
- Mhm.
Mama! Mama!
(Mann) Hilfe!
Kann mir jemand helfen?
In der Serie:
Kriegsinternierte helfen,
die Lawinenopfer zu bergen.
Andrin!
So auch in der Realität:
Im April 1917 verschüttet eine Lawine
einen Regionalzug.
Kriegsinternierte
helfen bei der Bergung.
Die Kriegsinternierten -
eine wichtige Spionagequelle.
Die medialen Bedingungen
im Ersten Weltkrieg
waren ja ganz anders.
Es war der Anfang des Funkes.
Luftüberwachung - es gab auch
Flugzeuge, aber noch wenige.
Deshalb war
das Wissen von Soldaten vor Ort
eine wichtige Informationsquelle.
Zurück nach Zürich.
Zurück zum Zufallsfund im Estrich
und dem Beginn
der grossen Spionageaffäre -
zu den Handgranaten
mit der deutschen Aufschrift:
"Vorsicht! Nicht verbeulen!"
"Vorsicht! Nicht verbeulen!",
eine deutsche Aufschrift.
"Vorsicht! Nicht verbeulen!"
Ich finde das Foto der Handgranaten
im Bundesarchiv.
Untersuchungsrichter Heusser
dokumentierte den Waffenfund
akribisch.
Seine Untersuchungen zeigen:
Ausgerechnet italienische Anarchisten
haben den Estrich gemietet.
Ich finde auch ein Bild
mit beschlagnahmten Zeitzündern,
Revolvern, Giftstoffen.
Untersuchungsrichter Heusser
entdeckt noch weitere Waffenverstecke
in Zürich, wiederum bei Anarchisten.
Im Bundesgericht Lausanne
sind bis heute sämtliche
Ermittlungsakten archiviert.
Heusser scheut keinen Aufwand,
lässt sogar mit den Bomben
Sprengversuche durchführen.
Sein Fazit: Gefährliche Waffen in den
Händen von gefährlichen Anarchisten.
Anarchisten -
damals als  d i e  grosse Bedrohung.
Anarchismus heisst ja eigentlich:
Ich lehne eine Herrschaft von
Menschen über andere Menschen ab,
grundsätzlich.
Dann kann ich mich
als Anarchisten bezeichnen.
Anarchismus heisst eigentlich
Herrschaftslosigkeit,
und das ist ein breites Spektrum
von politischen Bestrebungen.
Man muss sich natürlich vorstellen,
dass der Staat noch sehr viel mehr
als heute patriarchal
organisiert war, obrigkeitsgläubig.
Viele Leute,
die sich dem nicht fügen wollte,
wurden als Anarchisten bezeichnet
sowie als Bedrohung empfunden.
Entsprechend scharf ist die Reaktion
von Untersuchungsrichter Heusser:
Grüezi, könnten Sie mich
mit Bundesanwalt Stämpfli verbinden?
Danke.
Herr Bundesanwalt, grüezi.
Hier spricht Heusser.
Ich hab da
etwas sehr Interessantes für Sie.
Wir haben jemanden festgenommen,
einen Oreste De Luca oder so.
Er hat uns etwas gestanden.
In seiner Jackentasche
fanden wir eine Adresse
und machten eine Hausdurchsuchung.
Wir fanden aufrührerische
Flugblätter, Sprengstoffe,
Munition, Handgranaten usw. -
das ganze Programm.
Ja, genau.
Erhalte ich Ihre Einwilligung,
um gegen diese Anarchisten
vorzugehen?
Gut.
In den Akten des Bundesgerichts
sehe ich:
Heusser verhaftet
über 100 Anarchisten.
Sie sitzen monatelang
in Untersuchungshaft -
und schweigen hartnäckig.
Heusser kommt nicht weiter.
Er findet nicht heraus, von wem
die Anarchisten die Waffen erhielten.
Die Haftbedingungen sind harsch.
Zwei Anarchisten
begehen sogar Selbstmord.
Und es gibt Berichte,
wonach er Inhaftierten schlägt.
Es hagelt Proteste,
selbst in der bürgerliche Presse
erscheinen kritische Artikel.
Heusser muss sich rechtfertigen.
Das Interview Ð
nachgestellt mit Originalzitaten.
* Räuspern *
Ich musste
verschiedene Angeschuldigte
wegen ihres frechen,
ungebührlichen Auftretens
in Dunkelarrest verlegen.
Was die kritisierte Verpflegung
anbelangt,
dieser Übelstand ist eine Folge
der Kriegsrationierung.
Und den Lesestoff
musste ich entziehen,
weil sie mit den Büchern
untereinander korrespondierten.
Er führte die Untersuchung
sehr akribisch,
aber nur in eine Richtung:
Er wollte die Anarchistenszene
in der Schweiz radikal austrocknen
und beseitigen.
Das steht auch
in seinem Untersuchungsbericht.
Er wollte der Anarchistenszene
im Auftrag des Staates
den Garaus machen.
Er wollte sie beseitigen.
Wir wollten im Interesse des Staates
einen harten Schlag
gegen den Anarchismus führen,
ihn in seinem Lebensnerv treffen.
Viele Anarchisten
leben damals im Exil in die Schweiz.
Sie besitzt ein tolerantes Asylrecht.
Zudem weigert sich
die liberale Schweiz,
politische Flüchtlinge auszuliefern.
Die Anarchisten fühlen sich hier
sicher, organisieren sich neu:
Die Schweiz ist eine Art Heimatland
des internationalen Anarchismus,
weil hier
schon Anfang der 1870er-Jahre
die Fédération jurassienne
gegründet wurde,
eine anarchistische Strömung
innerhalb der internationalen
Arbeiterbewegung.
Verschiedenste,
auch politische Flüchtlinge
hielten sich in der Schweiz auf.
Z.B. die Revolutionäre
aus dem Zarenreich
oder die italienischen Anarchisten.
Internationales Aufsehen
erregte die Ermordung
der österreichischen Kaiserin
Elisabeth, der populären Sissi,
1898, durch einen Anarchisten,
der reuelos sagte:
"Die Herrschenden müssen weg,
die bringen Unheil über die Völker."
"Wir brauchen
eine andere Gesellschaftsordnung."
Heusser lässt
die Flugblätter analysieren.
Er will die anarchistischen Drucker
aufspüren.
Das Ergebnis -
für Heusser eine grosse Enttäuschung:
Es stellte sich heraus,
dass die Flugblätter
auf Papier gedruckt wurden, das
nur aus Deutschland stammen konnte.
Da Harz fehlte, verwendeten die
Deutschen Cellulose als Bindemittel.
Deshalb stammte das Papier
eindeutig aus Deutschland.
Trotz der Deutschland-Spur:
Heusser reagiert nicht,
er konzentriert sich weiter
auf die Anarchisten.
Heusser war auch lange
einer anderen Fährte auf der Spur,
bzw. er wollte Deutschlang als
Drahtzieher nicht weiter verfolgen.
Dann eine neue Wendung.
In den Akten des Bundesgerichts
sehe ich:
Im Juni 1918, ein halbes Jahr nach
dem Waffenfund im Zürcher Estrich,
denunziert die französische
Spionageabwehr einen Hans Schreck.
Dieser sei als deutscher Geheimagent
in die Affäre involviert.
Dr. Hans Schreck alias Dr. Angst
alias Dr. Röhme alias Dr. Feldmann -
der durchtriebene Spion
besitzt eine Vielzahl von Decknamen.
Trotz der Decknamen:
Spion Hans Schreck wird verhaftet.
Aus den beschlagnahmten Unterlagen
geht hervor:
Schreck - ein Meister der Fälschung.
Er besitzt eine Vielzahl von Stempeln
wie "Streng geheim!"
und Siegel.
Damit wandelt er
zahlreiche harmlose Schriftstücke um
in brisante Dokumente.
Alles archiviert im Bundesgericht.
(Christophe Vuilleumier)
Hans Schreck startet eigentlich
als kleiner Gauner.
Er wächst als Waise in einem
ärmlichen Quartier Berlins auf.
Die Polizei verhaftet ihn mehrmals
wegen Betrugs und Diebstahls.
Rasch wird er
zum raffinierten Betrüger.
Als der Erste Weltkrieg ausbricht,
findet er sofort
eine Stelle beim Geheimdienst.
Dort ist man begeistert
von seinen Talenten.
Schrecks Leben
besteht quasi nur aus Lügen.
Es ist extrem schwierig,
zu unterscheiden,
was bei ihm echt
und was gefälscht ist.
Wir wissen,
dass er zahlreiche Decknamen besass
und dass er bald zum Chef
der deutschen Spionageabwehr
in der Schweiz wird.
Deutschland begann, das aufzubauen,
was dann
der schweizerische Bundesrat 1919
eine terroristische Abteilung
des deutschen Generalstabs nennt.
Man hat also versucht,
über Spionage und Sabotage
dem Gegner einen Schaden zuzufügen.
Die Deutschen haben ziemlich
geschickt und vorausschauend
verschiedene längerfristige
Operationen organisiert.
Man muss sehen,
dass die Spionage
auch mit Sabotage verbunden ist,
mit Täuschungsmanövern,
mit Propaganda.
Also ein ganzes Feld
der Irreführung des Gegners,
der Information über einen sammelt.
Man möchte den Gegner täuschen
und in die Irre führen.
Wenn man sich mehr mit Spionage
und verdeckten Operationen in der
Schweiz beschäftigt, dann sieht man,
dass der Lenin-Zug der Anfang einer
v.a. von deutscher Seite
praktizierten Strategie war,
den Gegner
im Innern zu destabilisieren.
Der russische Kommunist Lenin
lebt als Flüchtling in Zürich.
Er leitet den bolschewistischen
Flügel der Kommunistischen Partei
und will,
dass Russland den Krieg einstellt.
Was Sie jetzt erfahren,
ist absolut vertraulich. Verstanden?
Im Gegensatz zum Zaren wollen die
Bolschewiki aus dem Krieg austreten.
Für Deutschland ...
- ... würde die Ostfront
in Russland wegfallen.
Der Kaiser könnte seine Kräfte
auf die Westfront konzentrieren.
Für Deutschland wäre es der
dringend benötigte Befreiungsschlag.
Wir haben diesen Revolutionären
nun gefunden.
Er nennt sich Lenin.
Wladimir Iljitsch Lenin.
Er lebt im Exil in Zürich.
Deutschland hielt es
für einen idealen Zeitpunkt,
um Russland
als Gegner auszuschalten,
indem die Revolution das Land,
das russische Imperium lahmlegt
und es damit als Kriegsgegner
nicht mehr infrage kommt.
Das Ziel der Deutschen war es,
Russland zu destabilisieren,
indem sie den wichtigsten Feind
des Zaren einschleusen.
Der Lenin-Zug.
Das deutsche Kaiserreich
erlaubt dem Bolschewisten Lenin
und seinen Anhängern
quer durch Deutschland zu reisen -
nach Russland,
begleitet von deutschen Offizieren.
Aussteigen in Deutschland
streng verboten.
Der Lenin-Zug
ist ein gutes Beispiel,
geradezu ein Paradebeispiel,
für die Instrumentalisierung
des Gegners für die eigenen Zwecke.
Lenin übernimmt in Russland
die Macht,
der Zar wird gestürzt und ermordet.
* Originalton auf Russisch *
Lenin schliesst mit Deutschland
im März 1918 einen Separatfrieden.
Für Russland
ist der Weltkrieg beendet .
Der Lenin-Zug hat genau das
bezweckt, was sie haben wollten:
Die Revolutionäre
kehrten nach Russland zurück.
Es kam zur russischen
Oktoberrevolution,
also zur bolschewistischen
Revolution.
Das hat das ganze Land
aus den Fugen gehoben,
und schliesslich
ist auch genau das eingetroffen,
was Deutschland wollte,
nämlich ein Separatfrieden
mit Russland in Brest Litowsk 1918.
Zurück zum deutschen Spion
Hans Schreck.
Vor seiner Verhaftung wohnt er im
idyllischen Leissigen am Thunersee.
Von hier steuert er
sein Agentennetzwerk.
Ich realisiere: Schreck ist nicht nur
in den Zürcher Waffenfund involviert.
Er wird auch Sabotageaktionen
an Rüstungsbetrieben in Frankreich
durchführen.
Und er wird eine Reihe
von Operationen
gegen den Schweizer Industriellen
Jules Bloch organisieren,
der im Auftrag der Franzosen
Munition herstellt.
Jules Bloch -
ein erfolgreicher Uhrenfabrikant.
Im Krieg bleiben die Kunden weg.
Bloch stellt um
auf Zünder-Produktion.
Es ist ziemlich einfach,
die Uhren-Produktion umzustellen
auf die Herstellung von Zündern.
Genau das tut Jules Bloch.
Er stellt in seinen Fabriken
Zünder für Granaten her.
Der Zünder ist der Teil,
der auf der Spitze der Granate sitzt
und die Explosion auslöst.
Bloch beliefert Frankreich
mit Zündern für Millionen
und Abermillionen
von französischen Franc.
Diese werden v.a.
in der Schlacht von Verdun
von der französischen Artillerie
eingesetzt.
Der deutsche Spion Schreck versucht,
Blochs Zünder-Exporte zu stoppen.
Er ist ein Ziel
für die deutschen Spionage.
Sie wollen ihn ausschalten,
weil er die französischen
Kriegsanstrengungen unterstützt.
Sie unternehmen mehrere Anläufe
und versuchen,
eine seiner Fabriken
in die Luft zu sprengen.
Das klappt nicht,
der Sprengsatz wird entdeckt.
Auch in der "Davos 1917"-Serie
werden Zünder produziert.
Was Hans Schreck nicht schafft,
gelingt in der Serie.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Ab 1917 beginnen
die Spionageorganisationen,
selbst in den Krieg
zu intervenieren,
mit Sabotageaktionen.
Sie sammeln nicht mehr
nur Informationen,
sondern versuchen
durch Kriegshandlungen,
das Kriegsgeschehen zu beeinflussen.
Man kann niemandem mehr trauen.
Es gibt ein gespenstisches
Spiegelkabinett
von Spionage und Gegenspionage,
von Information und Desinformation.
Das führt auch dazu,
dass das Leben in der Spionagewelt
sehr gefährlich wird.
Die Methoden werden immer rabiater.
Kuriere müssen
bewaffnet herumlaufen.
Es werden zunehmend Pistolen,
Bomben und Gas
bei Spionageaktionen eingesetzt.
Dann nochmals eine neue Wendung.
In den Akten sehe ich:
Untersuchungsrichter Heusser
verhaftet einen angeblichen
Anarchisten namens Erwin Briess.
In Wirklichkeit aber
ein englischer Agent:
Briess überwacht
für die Kolonialmacht England
indische Anarchisten in Zürich.
Ich sehe in den Akten:
Agent Briess durchschaut Schrecks
raffinierten Plan.
Der Plan: Deutschland sucht
die Nähe zu indischen Anarchisten.
Diese kämpfen
für die Unabhängigkeit von Indien,
gegen den deutschen Kriegsgegner
England.
Deutschland instrumentalisiert
die indischen Anarchisten -
ähnlich wie mit dem Lenin-Zug.
Alles fliegt auf, weil Spion Briess
die indischen Anarchisten überwacht.
Briess war 1915 bis 1918
als Spitzel
für die englische Polizei unterwegs.
Er hatte den Auftrag, die Inder
in der Schweiz auszuhorchen
und ihre Bewegungen
sowie Informationen über sie
nach London zu melden.
Erwin Briess
war eine sehr schillernde Figur.
Er war ein Studierter.
Er erwarb
die Schweizer Staatsbürgerschaft
und studierte danach
Kulturwissenschaften.
Er interessierte sich für Indologie
und hatte ein grosses Wissen
über den Orient.
Auf der Suche
nach einer festen Anstellung
landete er nicht ganz zufällig
beim britischen Geheimdienst.
Und so wird Spion Briess,
getarnt als Anarchist, Zeuge,
wie Deutschland
indische Anarchisten einspannt:
Und dann haben zwei dieser Inder ...
Chatto ...
Chattopadhyaya, genannt Chatto,
und Abdul Hafis
hatten vom deutschen Generalstab
den Auftrag,
den Bombenplot zu organisieren.
D.h., Bombenmaterial, Waffen
und Geld in Zürich an italienische
Anarchisten weiterzugeben.
Die indischen Anarchisten
bilden die Verbindung,
den sog. Go Between,
zu den italienischen Anarchisten.
Er berichtet selbst,
dass er in Zürich
vom Inder Abdul Hafis
aufgefordert worden war,
ihn zum Bahnhof zu begleiten.
Dort holten sie in der
Gepäckabteilung vom Bahnhof Zürich
eine Kiste ab.
Diese war
mit dem diplomatischen Kurier
von Deutschland
nach Bern spediert worden
und dann mit der SBB
von Bern nach Zürich.
Sie brachten die Kiste
in Briess' Büro.
Nachdem Hafis gegangen war,
öffnete Briess die Kiste
und sah,
dass die Kiste Sprengstoff enthielt.
Er kontaktierte sofort den
englischen Generalkonsul in Zürich.
Der Generalkonsul sagte ihm,
er solle die Situation
weiterhin genau beobachten
und melden, was passiert.
Nach einigen Tagen hat Hafis den
Sprengstoff zu Cavadini verschoben,
einen italienischen Anarchist
in Zürich.
Nach wochenlangen Verhören erzählte
mir der englische Agent Briess
endlich die Wahrheit,
nämlich dass er Zeuge wurde,
wie das deutsche Konsulat
die Anarchisten
mit Bomben und Waffen belieferte.
Da erinnerte ich mich an die Infor-
mation von Wachtmeister Steiner,
an die Handgranate
mit der Aufschrift:
"Vorsicht! Nicht verbeulen!"
Nach dem Geständnis von Spion Briess
realisiert Heusser:
Die Rolle des verhafteten Schreck
ist zentral.
Doch Spion Schreck versteht es
meisterhaft, Heusser hinzuhalten:
Er wisse von noch mehr Bomben,
von noch mehr Anarchisten.
"Vorsicht! Nicht verbeulen!"
Aber für Details müsse er zuerst
von seinen deutschen Vorgesetzten
grünes Licht erhalten.
Untersuchungsrichter Heusser
wartet und wartet.
Sein Differenzierungsvermögen
war sehr reduziert,
und er war deutschfreundlich.
Bei den Aussagen deutscher Agenten
wie Hans Schreck z.B.
war er jeweils so begeistert,
dass er sie gleich aus der
Untersuchungshaft entlassen wollte,
was bei einem Anarchisten
nie passiert wäre.
Er war also sehr parteiisch.
Immerhin realisiert Heusser: Es ist
eine verdeckte Spionageoperation
des deutschen Kaiserreichs.
Doch inzwischen
hat sich Schrecks Agentennetzwerk
bereits nach Deutschland abgesetzt,
Heusser kann die Helfershelfer
nicht mehr befragen.
Das Ergebnis meiner Untersuchungen
ist Folgendes:
Der terroristische Dienst,
eine rein militärische Organisation,
dem deutschen Generalstab
angegliedert,
engagiert das gefährlichste Milieu
überhaupt, die Anarchisten,
um Sabotageaktionen und Attentate
im feindlichen Gebiet durchzuführen.
Hochgefährlich Ð
ausgerechnet Anarchisten
mit Bomben und Waffen auszurüsten.
Der Lenin-Zug war im April 1917,
und die verdeckten Operationen
mit italienischen Anarchisten
in Zürich waren 1918.
Ich erkenne dort einen Lernprozess:
Deutschland hatte gemerkt, dass
die Rechnung vordergründig aufgeht.
Also dass sie eine innere
Destabilisierung des Feindes
durch Exilgruppen
herbeiführen können.
Durch sehr radikale Exilgruppen.
Dieselben Hoffnungen setzte man auch
in die italienischen Anarchisten.
Man ging davon aus,
dass sie eine Destabilisierung
des italienischen Staates,
die Absetzung des Königs
und damit auch ein Ausscheiden
Italiens herbeiführen könnten.
Im Grunde genommen war es also
eine sehr ähnliche Taktik.
Noch ist der blutige Krieg
in vollem Gang.
Wenn der deutsche Plan
geklappt hätte,
wenn die Polizei nicht zufällig
das Waffendepot entdeckt hätte -
der Krieg
wäre wahrscheinlich anders verlaufen.
Konkret sprach man von Anschlägen
auf den Ministerpräsidenten,
auf den Aussenminister
sowie von Anschlägen
auf den Bahnhof von Mailand
und auf die Banca d'Italia in Rom,
wo die Goldreserven lagen.
Das hätte sicher die italienischen
Kriegsanstrengungen beeinträchtigt.
Der Krieg gegen Österreich-Ungarn,
gegen die Mittelmächte,
hätte sich verlängert.
Die letzten italienischen Siege
auf dem Schlachtfeld
wären wohl nicht passiert.
Und Österreich-Ungarn
hätte wohl nicht so rasch
um einen Waffenstillstand
am 8. November gebeten.
Zurück ins Archiv,
zurück zum Dossier Schreck.
Der durchtriebene Spion Schreck
schafft es,
die Befragungen
immer weiter hinauszuzögern.
Dann wird er vom Gefängnis
in eine Klinik verlegt -
er sei nervenkrank, klagt er.
In den Unterlagen sehe ich,
was danach passiert:
Schreck flüchtet aus der Klinikzelle
und telegrafiert provokativ
nach Zürich:
"Bin gut in Deutschland gelandet."
"Entschuldigen Sie meinen Schritt.
Dr. Schreck."
Es ist richtig, dass ich seiner Frau
einen unbeaufsichtigten Besuch
in seiner Zelle gestattet habe.
Es galt ja eigentlich das Ehrenwort
eines deutschen Offiziers.
Nie hätte ich gedacht,
dass seine Frau ein 19 m langes Seil
in seine Zelle schmuggeln würde.
Es zeigt einmal mehr, wie Heusser
auf seinem deutschen Auge blind war.
Er hat allem, was von
Deutschland kam, blind vertraut.
Insofern sehe ich Schreck
als Zeichen dafür,
dass Heusser diese Seite
wirklich systematisch ignorierte.
Ich habe den Besuch nur gestattet,
weil ich das Interesse des Staates
im Auge behalten wollte.
Ich ging auch davon aus,
dass unsere Untersuchung
über den Sprengstoff
und die Handgranate
das Spionageverbrechen
von Herrn Dr. Schreck
an Wichtigkeit weit übertrifft.
1918,
als die Ermittlungen stattfinden,
befindet sich die Schweiz
in einer sehr vulnerablen Situation.
Sie ist nicht losgelöst
von den europäischen Entwicklungen
zu verstehen.
Seit 1917 wird regelmässig gestreikt
und demonstriert.
Es gibt Unruhe auf der Strasse,
auch Hungerproteste,
wegen der Lebensmittelknappheit
und Versorgungsengpässen.
In der Schweiz
brodelte es damals also sozial.
Man muss auch beachten,
wann das Ganze stattgefunden hat.
Das war im Sommer 1918
bis zum Frühsommer 1919.
In dieser Zeit herrschten
in der Schweiz soziale Unruhen.
Im November 1918
gab es einen Landesstreik.
Der Landesstreik:
Der Bundesrat bietet die Armee auf
gegen streikenden Arbeiter.
Das Bürgertum lebt in Angst
vor einer Revolution.
So auch der bürgerliche
Untersuchungsrichter Heusser:
Heusser fühlte sich beauftragt,
diese Bedrohung
in der Schweiz zu beseitigen.
Die Spannung ist spürbar.
Und die Prozessermittlungen
gegen die Anarchisten werden ja
von einem klar bürgerlichen
Untersuchungsrichter geleitet:
Heusser.
Nun, sagen wir, das Ganze ist
in diesem Kontext äusserst heikel.
Dann endlich, November 1918: Frieden.
Deutschland und Österreich-Ungarn
haben kapituliert,
der Krieg ist vorbei.
Das internationale Kräfteverhältnis
hat sich so verändert,
dass Deutschland
seien Machtstatus verlor
und man auch in der Schweiz
nicht mehr auf Deutschland setzte.
Im Unterschied zu vorher herrschte
nun eine Anti-Deutschland-Stimmung.
Teils gab es auch Wut
den Deutschen gegenüber.
Und so ging der Prozess dann
in einer anderen Stimmungslage
über die Bühne.
Jetzt erst findet der Prozess
über den Waffenfund
im Zürcher Estrich statt,
im Juni 1919.
Trotz der Flucht von Spion Schreck
und seinen Helfershelfern.
Angeklagt sind 20 Anarchisten.
Für den Hauptangeklagten
fordert der Staatsanwalt
fünfeinhalb Jahre Gefängnis.
Der Prozess endet
mit einer grossen Überraschung:
Das Bundesstrafgericht findet,
Heusser könne nicht beweisen,
welche Anarchisten tatsächlich in die
Attentatspläne eingeweiht waren.
Wenn die deutschen Drahtzieher
vor Gericht gestanden hätten,
wäre es anders gekommen.
Das Gericht stellte dann fest,
dass Heussers Fakten
in keiner Art und Weise
für eine Verurteilung reichten.
Er stellte die Untersuchung
gegen die Anarchisten
ins Zentrum seiner Anklage,
ohne sich für die deutsche Spur
zu interessieren.
Die Anklage ist zusammengebrochen,
und Bundesrichter Soldati
verstand es,
den rechtsstaatlichen Grundsätzen
Nachdruck zu verschaffen.
Die Schweizer Justiz hat in einer
Rechtsförmlichkeit gearbeitet,
die mich beeindruckt.
Wenn die Beweislage
nicht gegeben war,
wenn es irgendwelche herbei-
phantasierte Zusammenhänge sind,
die sich nicht
substanziieren lassen ...
Und so wurde dann der Grossteil
der Anarchisten freigesprochen.
Für Heusser eine grosse Schlappe.
Das hartnäckige Leugnen
dieser gefährlichen Anarchisten
hat leider
zu diesen Freisprüchen geführt.
Dr. Schreck hat mir aber
übrigens noch gestanden,
dass es
noch weitere Waffenverstecke gab.
Er sagte,
er sei an den Diensteid gebunden.
Leider.
Heusser hat vor Gericht
ja eigentlich verloren,
wenn man das so krass sagen darf.
Aber in den Augen des Stadtzürcher
Bürgertums hatte er gewonnen.
In dem Sinne,
dass er Willen gezeigt hat,
scharf und hart
gegen Linke vorzugehen.
Und so wurde er
kurz nach dem Prozess
zum Polizeichef
der Stadt Zürich gewählt.
Er bekam dann Probleme mit dem
sozialdemokratisch gewählten Zürich.
1928 wurde er nicht mehr bestätigt
als Chef der Polizei.
Grund dafür war meiner Meinung nach
seine politischen Einstellung
und seine professionelle
Unfähigkeit.
Er war für diesen Posten
nicht mehr brauchbar.
Und das offizielle Deutschland?
Im "Berner Tagblatt"
behauptet der deutsche Botschafter:
Es habe nie eine Zusammenarbeit
mit Anarchisten gegeben.
Dank der Archive in Deutschland,
die zugänglich sind, weiss man,
dass die Behauptung der Deutschen,
sie hätten nichts davon gewusst,
völlig falsch ist.
Es liegen Korrespondenzen
des damaligen deutschen Gesandten
in Bern vor.
Das Dementieren
von verdeckten Operationen
ist auch Teil vom Spiel,
sowohl im Ersten Weltkrieg
wie auch jetzt.
Begleitet wird das immer auch
mit einer ganz grossen
Desinformationskampagne,
und die sind absolut vergleichbar
zwischen dem Ersten Weltkrieg
und der heutigen Situation.
Beispielsweise der Überfall
von Russland auf die Ukraine -
ein klarer Verstoss
gegen das Völkerrecht.
Auch hier: Verdeckte Operationen.
Wie die Explosion
der Nord-Stream-Pipeline.
Es ist eine Geheimdienstoperation,
ein Sabotageakt.
Aber von wem?
Es gibt mehrere Spuren.
Die Geschichte wird uns vielleicht
eines Tages zeigen,
wer dahintersteckt. Aber das sind
sehr aktuelle Operationen.
Die einen vermuten,
die Russen schlugen einen Vorteil,
andere wiederum
sehen einen Vorteil für die Ukraine.
Das liegt unter der Dunstglocke
von Vermutungen
über die Strategien
der einzelnen Länder.
Klar ist jedoch, dass es immer darum
geht, Verunsicherung zu schaffen.
Ich denke, verdeckte Operationen
gehören zum Standardrepertoire
von Nachrichtendiensten
und von Regierungen.
Es ist also wenig überraschend,
dass auch im aktuellen Krieg
verdeckte Operationen stattfinden,
sowohl im Feindesland
als auch in benachbarten Ländern.
Was passierte nach dem Prozess mit
dem englischen Spion Erwin Briess?
Er, der damals die verdeckte
deutsche Operation enthüllte.
Briess war eigentlich
eine tragische Figur.
Er ist eine nicht untypische Figur
der Spionagewelt
des Ersten Weltkriegs.
Er geriet auch oft
mit der Polizei in Konflikt,
wegen Nachtruhestörung,
Schlägereien ...
Handel mit pornografischem Material.
Er wurde auch wegen
Urkundenfälschung angeklagt, usw.
Er fand keinen Halt mehr.
Und das Schicksal
des geflüchteten Spions Hans Schreck?
Er setzt seine Karriere
im Nachrichtendienst fort.
Er organisiert
weitere Täuschungsmanöver,
z.B. im Zusammenhang
mit dem Völkerbund in Genf.
Er mischt sich auch ein in die
Innenpolitik Grossbritanniens.
Hans Schreck
war ein Agentennaturell.
Er hätte gerne in den wichtigen
Kreisen der Gesellschaft brilliert,
überall angedockt,
Informationen herausgeholt.
Wir finden seine Spur
nochmals im Jahr 1932,
diesmal in den Archiven
des französischen Geheimdienstes.
Es gibt dort einen Bericht, der
sagt, dass Schreck in Saint-Louis,
also in der Nähe von Basel -
ich zitiere - "liquidiert wurde".
Wahrscheinlich
von französischen Agenten,
die ihn seit einiger Zeit
im Visier hatten.
Liquidiert durch den
französischen Geheimdienst:
Auch die Karriere des Spions
und Meisterfälschers Hans Schreck
endet im Alter von 52 Jahren
tragisch.
Untertitelung: Sucevic Solutions
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2023